this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learned to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on a link in the description
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because the president could use
some good advice unlike the bad legal
advice he seems to be getting at the
moment today we're going to discuss one
of the newest scandals to rock the White
House the allegations of bribery and
potential abuse of power by President
Trump in exchange for getting dirt on
presidential candidate Joe Biden all
hell seems to be breaking loose here in
Washington and although you could
probably say that on any given day this
time it seems to be a little different
because of one thing House Democrats
have announced that they are formally
opening an inquiry into the impeachment
of the President of the United States
this doesn't happen every day to
understand how we got here you need to
know the facts about Donald Trump's
conversation with the president of
Ukraine a mysterious high-level
whistleblower the many faces of Rudy
Giuliani and what all of that has to do
with Joe Biden's son so to take a step
back Ukraine is a country in Eastern
Europe that was formerly a part of the
Soviet Union the country currently has a
rocky relationship with Russia because
Russian troops have invaded part of
Ukraine's territory the Crimea back in
2014 Ukrainian citizens protested
Russian involvement in their government
asking President Viktor Yanukovych for
conspiring with Russia now the United
States and most of the world condemned
Russia and warned it against further
interference in Ukrainian sovereignty
later that same year then Vice President
Biden went to Ukraine to deliver us aid
now fast forward a few years in July of
2019 The Washington Post reported that a
high-ranking intelligence official had
filed a whistleblower complaint about
promises that President Trump had made
during communication and interaction
with a foreign leader several news
organizations reported that this
whistleblower complaint involved
president Trump promising aid to Ukraine
if they dug up some dirt on hunter Biden
Joe Biden's son Trump himself confirmed
part of the story hunter Biden was a
member of the board of a company called
Purisima Holdings the largest gas
company in Ukraine that company was
known for having some ties to former
president of Ukraine Viktor Vienna
Kovich hunter Biden remained a board
member of verismo until 2019
so what is the deal with this
intelligence community whistleblower
well I probably don't need to tell you
that it is incredibly unusual for a
member of the intelligence community to
number one file a whistleblower
complaint there are strict guidelines
that one must follow in order to blow
the whistle on the intelligence
community and it is almost unheard of
that a whistleblower would blow the
whistle on the President of the United
States that just has never happened
before and on September 9th intelligence
community general inspector or the IC IG
Michael Atkinson informed
representatives Adam Schiff and Devon
Nunez who are on the House Intelligence
Committee that he had forwarded a
whistleblower report to Acting Director
of National Intelligence Joseph McGuire
a whistleblower is a person who exposes
information that he or she believes is
illegal or unethical governmental
whistleblowers are not unusual but a
whistleblower at this level of the
government in the intelligence community
making an allegation of the president
absolutely is incredibly unusual
inspector Atkinson determined that the
report was quote an urgent concern end
quote and quote credible urgent and
credible are two statutory requirements
that require the IC IG to forward the
complaint to Congress atkinson's ruling
immediately made this a very serious
allegation that Congress wanted to
review however Acting Director of
National Intelligence McGuire
stepped in to claim that the complaint
was not required to be released to
Congress now remember this fact about
Acting DNI McGuire as we'll come back to
it later this fact could be the first
indication of a cover-up by the White
House and the Department of Justice at
the time of this video we don't have all
of the facts we don't have the entire IC
IG complaint but news reports are
indicating that President Trump may have
threatened to withhold
400 million dollars in military aid to
Ukraine if it did not investigate hunter
Biden among other things the Trump
administration had criticized the Obama
administration for not providing lethal
foreign aid to Ukraine in its fight
against Russia so earlier this year
Congress appropriated almost 400 million
dollars in military aid 250 million
dollars in explicit military aid and 150
million dollars going through the State
Department that can be
for lethal force by the Ukrainians to
buy military goods from the Americas the
argument of course being that Ukraine
needs that military aid to help fight
against Russia in Crimea and was
approved by the Pentagon and Congress
however for months president Trump froze
that military aid some reports indicate
the government employees were instructed
to obfuscate or lie to Congress about
the reason for why that money was frozen
it's not necessarily unusual to freeze
this kind of military aid but under
these circumstances it appears to be
highly unusual and we'll get to why in
just a moment although there is much
speculation over the contents of the
whistleblower report president Trump and
his personal lawyer and advisor Rudy
Giuliani started confirming aspects of
this particular story just days after it
was broken President Trump spoke with
new ukrainian President Volodya Mir
zalenski by telephone on July 25th just
days after Robert Muller had testified
in Congress when President Trump
allegedly mentioned his desire to have
Biden investigated up to eight times
according to Trump he summarizes phone
calls saying we had a great conversation
conversation I had was largely
congratulatory
was largely corruption all of the
corruption taking place was largely the
fact that we don't want our people like
Vice President Biden is done creating to
me corruption already in the Ukraine and
Ukraine brains got a lot of problems
President Trump to scrumming the phone
call as quote perfect it's very
important to talk about corruption have
you not talked about corruption why
would you give money to a country that
you think is corrupt so it's very
important that on occasion you speak to
somebody about corruption so President
Trump agrees that he spoke about alleged
corruption by the Biden's and that he
also was reluctant to give money to
Ukraine because he says the country is
corrupt a potential flaw with this
argument is that the United States gives
military aid to many different countries
not the least of which is Saudi Arabia
but the president does not seem to be
doing any kind of corruption analysis
with respect to those other countries
this may be specifically geared towards
Ukraine and these unusual circumstances
the president Trump wasn't done yet
speaking a few days later at the United
Nations President Trump said Joe Biden
and his son are corrupt all right but
the fake news doesn't want to report it
because they're Democrats if that ever
happened if a Republican ever did what
Joe Biden did if a Republican ever said
what Joe Biden said they're beginning
the electric chair by right now so what
is it that President Trump alleges the
Biden's did President Trump alleges that
Joe Biden used American Financial Aid to
pressure the Ukrainian government to
fire its top prosecutor in 2016 the
theory is that the prosecutor Victor's
shokan was investigating Ukraine's
largest gas company Purisima although
president Trump has been vague about
what the Biden's did that deserved this
so-called electric chair the corruption
allegations have been investigated and
dismissed Shokan was accused of being
soft on corruption the United States was
not alone in calling for his ouster
other Western nations in the entire
European Union also called on Ukraine to
remove him and the Ukrainian Parliament
eventually voted to remove Shogun
according to Bloomberg News which did an
extensive report on the matter in 2019
the burries my investigation had already
been dead for about a year by
the time that Vice President Biden
called for shokhin to be sacked and
there is no indication that hunter Biden
personally was being investigated for
corruption the former Ukrainian
prosecutor general told Bloomberg that
he found no evidence of wrongdoing by
either Biden but president Trump would
not let that debunks story die stating
Biden quote said I'm not going to give
billions of dollars to Ukraine unless
they remove this prosecutor and they
removed the prosecutor supposedly in one
hour and the prosecutor was prosecuting
the company of the son and the son
he just shouldn't have said that now as
far as my conversation it was perfect it
was a perfect conversation as you may be
aware Joe Biden has consistently been
the Democratic frontrunner against
President Trump in the twenty20
presidential election and has
consistently led Donald Trump in
head-to-head polls president Trump and
Rudy Giuliani have already confirmed
many aspects although not all of the
aspects of this particular story so
what's going up with Rudy Giuliani you
may ask well Rudy Giuliani is one of the
president's personal lawyers he has no
formal job with the US government but
allegedly has been acting as a messenger
for President Trump with Ukraine and
another one of mr. Giuliani's legendary
TV appearances Giuliani has admitted
that he spent several months pressuring
Ukraine for dirt on the Biden's
appearing on Chris Cuomo's CNN program
Giuliani said the only thing I asked
about Joe Biden is to get to the bottom
of how it was that would Senko who was
appointed right dismissed the case
against until you did ask Ukraine to
look into Joe Biden of course I did so
we already know that Giuliani met with
Ukrainian officials in May and August of
this year the August meeting was just a
week after President Trump froze all of
the military aid that Congress and the
Pentagon had appropriated for Ukraine
Giuliani said that during the August
meeting a Ukrainian official promised to
quote get to the bottom end quote of the
Biden situation The Wall Street Journal
reported that this was part of an
ongoing effort by President Trump to
have the Ukrainians work with Giuliani
to find some dirt on the Biden's in
exchange for the promised aid now on its
face there are major problems with
Giuliani's role in all of this Giuliani
is not a member of the US government and
should not be conducting u.s. foreign
policy and if Giuliani is conducting
u.s. foreign policy
then attorney-client privilege can't
attach to communications between the
president and his advisor now there of
course may be executive privilege issues
here but it would be highly unusual to
have executive privilege with your own
personal lawyer additionally if the US
government needs foreign assistance with
an investigation there are proper
channels to go through if there is a
mutual legal assistance treaty or M lat
in place between countries then that's
the proper outlet for asking for a
foreign country to investigate
particular crimes the US has an M lat
with Ukraine so the proper channels for
this would be for the DOJ to talk to the
State Department to talk to the legal
attache in the Ukrainian embassy which
would then liaised with law enforcement
agencies in Ukraine suffice to say the
proper channel is not your personal
lawyer rudy giuliani
and while i am loath to give any
credibility to the crazy things that
rudy giuliani says i think it is worth
going into what rudy giuliani claims in
this particular case so i know i've
thrown a ton of facts at you but here's
a timeline of what i think we know right
now this is a fluid situation it's
changing hour by hour believe me I have
tried to make this video for several
days but the facts just keep changing
but here's what I think we know right
now
on may 10th 2019 Rudy Giuliani cancels a
trip to Ukraine just one day after
saying he would be quote meddling in an
investigation and giving Ukraine's new
government quote reasons why they
shouldn't stop it because that
information will be very very helpful to
my client end quote
shortly thereafter on July 25th
President Trump talks with new ukrainian
prime minister zalenski on the phone
according to Ukraine's readout of the
call president Trump indicated that
Ukraine should quote complete
investigation in corruption cases which
inhibited the interaction between
Ukraine and the United States oh hold on
this breaking news and my life the whole
transcript has been released all right
we'll get to that in just a second on
August 28th Politico reported that
President Trump froze hundreds of
millions of dollars in aid to Ukraine
and Congress is in the dark about why on
September 1st Vice President Mike Pence
meets with zalenski in Poland on
September 9th after learning about the
whistleblower complaint the House
Foreign Affairs Intelligence and
oversight committees announced an
investigate
into whether President Trump and
Giuliani have quote increased pressure
on the Ukrainian government and its
justice system in service of president
Trump's re-election campaign the next
day on September 10th Intelligence
Committee Chairman shift begins
corresponding with acting DNI McGuire
about the whistleblower complaint on
September 11th the White House releases
the military aid to Ukraine on September
19th when reports emerge that Ukraine
may be the subject of the IC IG
complaint Giuliani tells CNN that he
told Ukraine to investigate Biden this
is confirmed on Twitter where he says
that the Biden's quote built millions of
dollars from Ukraine and billions from
China after House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
announced a formal impeachment inquiry
on Tuesday night President Trump decided
to release the full readout of the call
with Solinsky in full unclassified so if
you'll give me one second
okay so we're back I have the transcript
homeboy so as president Trump indicated
it does start off with a congratulation
of President szalinski but things take a
turn for the worse as we go further down
this transcript early in the call
President Trump
starts talking about the aid that the
u.s. is supposed to offer to Ukraine
saying I will say that we do a lot for
Ukraine we spend a lot of effort in a
lot of time much more than European
countries are doing and they should be
helping you more than they are he goes
on to say the United States has been
very very good to Ukraine I wouldn't say
that it's reciprocal necessarily because
things are happening that are not good
but the United States has been very very
good to Ukraine at that point president
zalenski acknowledges the aid the United
States is supposed to be providing and
goes one step further he says I'm very
grateful to you for that because the
United States is doing quite a lot for
Ukraine we are ready to continue to
cooperate for the next step specifically
we are almost ready to buy more javelins
which are missiles from the United
States for defense purposes and as some
background this is how military aid from
the United States works you provide a
boatload of money to a specific country
and they in turn give that right
United States arms makers who provide
the arms to the foreign countries so in
a way it's almost a subsidy for American
arms makers as much as it is foreign aid
to another country it's at that point
that President Trump asks president
zalenski for a favor he says I would
like you to do us a favor though because
our country has been through a lot and
Ukraine knows a lot about it I would
like you to find out what happened with
this whole situation with Ukraine they
say clouds strike that appears to be a
reference to aq non level insane
conspiracy theory that the Ukrainians
had conducted the Russian hacking that
was against the Democratic National
Convention the DNC hired this company
cloud strike and there is a crackpot
theory that the Ukrainians were involved
somehow I'm I refuse to go any further
than that
he continues I guess you have one of
your wealthy people there's an ellipsis
there maybe more there that's not
contained in this readout but we don't
know why there is an ellipsis at this
point the server they say Ukraine has it
there are a lot of things that went on
the whole situation I think you're
surrounding yourself with some of the
same people I would like to have the
attorney general that's attorney general
bar call you or your people and I would
liked you to get to the bottom of it so
there we have the first thing that
president Trump wants from the
Ukrainians which is to investigate the
Democrats the server I think this is a
reference to Hillary's emails and the
the Democratic National Convention
hacking at that point president Solinsky
goes on to say and respond I would also
like and hope to see him having your
trust that's the ambassador and your
confidence and having personal
relationships with you so we can
cooperate even more so I will personally
tell you that one of my assistants spoke
with Giuliani just recently so zolensky
has been coordinating with Rudy Giuliani
at that point there is a pivot to the
Biden's President Trump says I heard you
had a prosecutor who was very good and
he was shut down and that's really
unfair a lot of people are talking about
that the way they shut you were very
good prosecutor down and you had some
very bad people involved mr. Giuliani is
a highly respected man he was
the mayor of New York City a great mayor
and I would like him to call you I will
ask him to call you along with the
Attorney General
again that's Attorney General Bar Rudy
very much knows what's happening and he
is a very capable guy if you could speak
to him that would be great the former
ambassador from the United States the
woman was bad news and the people she
was dealing with in the Ukraine were bad
news so I just wanted to let you know
that the other thing there's a lot of
talk about Biden's son the Biden's
stopped the prosecution and a lot of
people want to find out about that so
whatever you can do with the Attorney
General would be great Biden went around
bragging that he stopped the prosecution
so if you could look into it ellipses we
don't know what else is there it sounds
horrible to me zalinsky responds and
goes on to say the next prosecutor
general will be 100% my person my
candidate who will be approved by the
Parliament and will start as a new
prosecutor in September he or she will
look into the situation specifically to
the company that you mentioned in this
issue which presumably is verismo so
there you have it this may not be an
explicit quid pro quo but this is about
as close as you can get
president Trump asks for an
investigation into the 2016 hacking and
cloud strike and the other thing that he
asked for was an investigation into Joe
Biden and Joe Biden's son now finally I
will mention parenthetically that at the
very end of this conversation the
Ukrainian president makes it a point to
tell Donald Trump one thing and that is
he says I would like to tell you that I
also have quite a few Ukrainian friends
that live in the United States actually
last time I traveled to the United
States I stayed in New York near Central
Park and I stayed at Trump Tower so all
of those people who have been talking
about the emoluments cases that are
going on in the fourth and second
circuit just got a whole lot of
information that foreign officials like
to stay and Trump properties for the
purpose of influencing the president
Donald Trump now I want to emphasize
that this is not a verbatim transcript
of the telephone call this is just a
readout it's a summary based on
impressions and based on auto
recognition software so it doesn't
convey everything that went into this
conversation and there may be more
nuanced than
appears just on the the drive written
page and additionally there may be
additional context that would help
understand this conversation itself okay
alright ABC News is now reporting that
the Ukrainians were briefed ahead of
time by the Trump administration telling
them that this conversation was going to
discuss the Biden allegations and it was
basically going to be all about what the
Ukrainians could do to gin of
information about the Biden's so yeah I
guess in terms of additional context it
just makes it worse that the Ukrainians
knew ahead of time that this was gonna
be about the Biden conspiracy theory now
I also want to emphasize that this
readout of the July 25th call is just
one of the instances mentioned
apparently in the whistleblower
complaint and that there could be much
more out there we don't know we'll need
to see not only the whistleblower
complaint but all the underlying
evidence so that takes us to the
whistleblower complaint and the
whistleblower the intelligence community
whistleblowers statute is set up to
provide a pathway for individuals to
come forward with allegations of urgent
concern in a way that does not endanger
classified information wait hold on a
second oh come on all right
apparently the whistleblower complaint
is out give me one second geez okay I
now have the whistleblower complaint in
its unclassified form and things keep
getting worse this is insane
so let's just go over the new
allegations of the whistleblower
complaint itself and we can talk about
the repercussions thereof so it starts
out as sort of summarizing what we
already knew from the transcript of the
phone call with zalenski and Trump this
whistleblower is concerned that the
president was using the power of his
office to solicit interference from a
foreign country the president's personal
lawyer Rudolph Giuliani is a central
figure in this effort and attorney
general bar appears to be involved as
well the involvement of bar
himself may require him to be recused
from further proceedings I guess we'll
have to learn more information about
that but this whistleblower says over a
half dozen US officials have informed
him of the various facts related to this
case
now the whistleblower whose identity we
still don't yet know is forthright and
says that they were not a direct witness
to some of the events that they are
describing in a relying on the testimony
of somewhere between six and over a
dozen individuals in the White House and
the intelligence community but that they
are concerned that the actions that they
have credible reports of pose risks to
u.s. national security and undermine the
US government efforts to deter and
counter foreign interference in u.s.
elections this whistleblower then goes
on to talk about the July 25th phone
call that we now have the readout of and
sort of summarizes the main events of
that phone call it's interesting to note
that the the readout that the White
House released first before releasing
the whistleblower complaint effectively
corroborates exactly what this person is
summarizing here it's not clear if this
whistleblower was privy to that readout
or not but the information that this
person had apparently was spot-on as we
already knew from the readout of the
call Trump did indeed use the
opportunity to advance his personal
interests in the call with the Ukrainian
prime minister as the whistleblower
talks about pressuring the Ukrainian
leader to take steps to help the
president's 2020 election bid the
information that is summarized in this
whistleblower complaint appears to jive
with the transcript itself that talks
about the president trying to encourage
an investigation into Vice President
Biden and his son asking the Ukrainians
in help uncovering that allegations of
Russian interference in the 2016 US
presidential election originated in
Ukraine and there's a footnote to this
particular
allegation where the whistleblower drops
a footnote and says I do not know why
the president associates these servers
with Ukraine which is just throwing
shade on the insane conspiracy theory
that relates to crowd
strike the dnc and the the Russian
hacking it appears to show that the
president still in 2019 believes the
Russians were not involved in the
hacking and that he believes this crazy
conspiracy theory so even the IC
community is not it's not buying the
president's conspiracy theory nonsense
and then going further that the
president asked the president of Ukraine
to talk to his personal envoy's mr.
Giuliani and attorney general Barr to
whom the president referred to multiple
times in tandem I mean this alone again
not only implicates Rudy Giuliani in
malfeasance but also Attorney General
Barr Congress is going to have to follow
up and find out what Rudy Giuliani said
to whom and when as well as what
attorney general bars involvement was as
well and it may require attorney general
Barr to recuse himself from everything
related to this scandal the complaint
talks about being deeply disturbed and
that many people in addition to the ones
already discussed were concerned that
they had witnessed the president abused
his office for personal gain and the
whistleblower talks about how
precautions had not been taken in
advance of the phone call because
everyone expected that it would be a
routine call with a foreign leader so
then we get to a particularly concerning
portion of this complaint and these are
new allegations that were not revealed
as part of the transcript readout which
is that apparently the White House has
engaged in efforts to restrict access to
the phone call because either President
Trump or those associated with President
Trump knew that the actions that have
been taken had crossed a line
so this whistleblower alleges that in
the days following the phone call I
learned from multiple US officials that
senior White House officials had
intervened to lock down all records of
the phone call especially the official
word-for-word transcript of the call
that was produced as is customary by the
White House Situation Room this
whistle blower goes on to say that the
White House officials told me that they
were quote directed by White House
lawyers White House lawyers to remove
the electronic transcript from the
computer system in which such
transcripts are typically stored for
coordination finalization and
distribution to cabinet-level officials
instead the transcript was loaded into a
separate electronic system that is
otherwise used to store and handle
classified information of an especially
sensitive nature one White House
official described this act as an abuse
of the electronic system because the
call did not contain anything remotely
sensitive from a national security
perspective this has shades of the Nixon
White House that often it's the cover-up
that's worse than the initial crime
itself but here I mean both are just
bonkers in terms of the abuse of power
and also the cover-up therein I mean not
only did President Trump potentially
engage in an abuse of power potentially
bribery potentially extortion but also
those around him are taking steps to
cover up those efforts to extort the
Ukrainian president this is bad I I just
I don't see a other side to this this is
on par if not worse than what was
uncovered in the 1974 work aid scandal I
just I don't see a second side to this
and in fact the report goes on to say
that during the same time frame multiple
US officials told me that the Ukrainian
leadership was led to believe that a
meeting or phone call between the
president and president Solinsky would
depend on whether zalenski showed a
willingness to play ball on the issues
that had been publicly aired by mister
Lysenko and mr. Giuliani mr. Lysenko is
the prosecutor who was fired for
corruption and finally the public
portion of this complaint ends within
mid-july I learned of a sudden change of
policy with respect to US assistance for
Ukraine that ends the unclassified
portion of the whistleblower complaint
which leads to a classified appendix
only parts of which have been revealed
there are two things that are really
interesting about this classified
appendix
the first is in the first subsection
this whistleblower states that according
to White House officials I spoke with
this was quote not the first time under
this administration that a presidential
transcript was placed into this codeword
level system solely for the purpose of
protecting politically sensitive rather
than national security sensitive
information that is an incredible
bombshell that the White House is
covering up other information that is
politically damaging to president Trump
and squirreling it away in a system that
was designed for national security
information obviously Congress is going
to want to investigate the other
instances of abusing this system and the
Director of National Intelligence this
is exactly what they should be looking
into this kind of abuse of the national
security apparatus finally this
whistleblower complaint talks about the
games that were being played with the
400 million dollars of foreign military
aid that was supposed to go to Ukraine
and states that on 18 July an office of
management and budget that's OMB
officially informed departments and
agencies of the president quote earlier
that month had issued instructions to
suspend all US security assistance to
Ukraine that is the four hundred million
dollars in aid neither OMB nor the NSC
staff knew why this instruction had been
issued during the interagency meetings
on 23 July and 26 July OMB officials
again stated explicitly that the
instruction to suspend this assistance
had come directly from the president but
they were still unaware of a policy
rationale as of early August
I heard from US officials that some
Ukrainian officials were aware that US
aid might be in jeopardy but I do not
know how or when they learned of it that
is the Pro to the quid in the quid pro
quo of this whole situation is that
there was strange instruction relayed by
Mick Mulvaney saying that the aid was
not supposed to be dispersed and that
alone could be a dereliction of duty -
for the executive branch not to enforce
the laws of the country which had been
appropriated by the Pentagon and
Congress but that it was done in a time
frame that makes it very much look like
it was done to make the Ukrainians quote
play ball as this complaint alleges this
is this is incredibly damning and very
very worrisome I don't know that there's
two ways about it
there may not be an explicit quid pro
quo and that the president literally
says you must do this you know in order
to receive the foreign aid but all of
the circumstances make it seem like that
is exactly what was implied that the
Ukrainians understood the rules of the
game and that they wanted to play ball
and the president may have abused his
power his the power of the office of the
presidency in order to get dirt on
political rivals you might recall that
the first volume of the Moller report
found that there was no collusion no
conspiracy no criminal conspiracy with
Russia because the Trump campaign had
not solicited the information had they
done so it's implicit in the mole report
that they would have been guilty of a
criminal conspiracy and it's almost as
if they took the Muller report as a road
map to then say okay well we'll then go
out and do it ourselves this is the kind
of action the kind of proactive seeking
of information that is what criminal
conspiracies are made of so with that
that takes us to the actual process of
the whistleblower complaint when
Atkinson described the process he said
it was meant to allow people who
complained to contact congressional
intelligence committees directly the
first step is to go to the IG the
Inspector General the IG then has two
weeks to conduct a preliminary
investigation into whether the complaint
is both credible and of urgent concern
an urgent concern is considered to be a
quote serious or flagrant problem abuse
violation of the law of executive order
or deficiency the IG is then supposed to
relay the complaint up the chain of
command and share his preliminary
findings with a Director of National
Intelligence the DNI the DEA is then
charged with giving that information to
congressional oversight committees in
this particular case this was not done
on the contrary Acting DNI McGuire hired
a lawyer to send a letter asserting that
quote no statute requires disclosure of
the complaint to the intelligence
committees because quote the disclosure
in this
did not concern allegations of conduct
by a member of the intelligence
community or involve an intelligence
activity under the DNI supervision
essentially Maguire is disagreeing with
his own inspector general determination
that the information in the complaint is
credible and urgent but a close reading
of 50 USC 30 33 suggests that the DNI
may lack the authority to overrule the
IG on this determination now September
17th response to Representative shift
McGuire refused to release the report to
Congress citing three particular
criteria one the whistleblower report
does not meet the definition of urgent
concern to the complaint concerned
someone outside of the intelligence
community presumably the President of
the United States and three the report
was unrelated to intelligence activities
it doesn't appear in the statute that
the DNI has the authority to overrule
the factual findings of the IC IG in
finding that the whistleblowers
complaint was both credible and urgent
but by the same token if the OLC or the
Department of Justice has issued an
opinion that says that they can't turn
over that information then the IC IGS
hands may be tied but by the same token
that may itself constitute an
obstruction of justice so we'll see how
this shakes out because it doesn't seem
like this is going away anytime soon but
I want to emphasize again that it would
be very helpful to hear from acting DNI
McGuire as to how all of these events
went down what oh come on
all right McGuire just testified
apparently so
director McGuire says that when he
received the urgent and credible
complaint from the whistleblower and the
IC IG he then took it up the chain of
command to get a an opinion from the
Office of Legal Counsel and a DOJ and
also to get counsel from the White House
about whether executive privilege
applies the problem with that
and in normal circumstances that's
probably the right thing to do but the
problem here is that it's the White
House
and the attorney general who is the head
of the Department of Justice who were
implicated in this whistleblower
complaint
I don't know that McGuire was wrong to
get their opinions but man it looks bad
when
a person or persons who are accused of a
crime and an abuse of power are the ones
that you're asking if you can release
the whistleblower complaint but for now
at least we have the readout /
transcript we have the complaint from
the whistleblower I'm sure in the coming
weeks and months we will hear from the
whistleblower themselves we will hear
from potentially the White House
officials and members of the
intelligence community who are mentioned
in this whistleblower complaint we will
hear from the Inspector General of the
intelligence community will probably get
more information but it's hard to
imagine what could possibly be worse
than what we already know now what's on
the record but one thing is for certain
this is not going to go away this has
already implicated dozens of officials
in the White House the story is is only
going to get bigger over time this is
not going to go away this is not a small
thing this is not the news glomming on
to some small nitpick this appears to be
on par if not far exceeding what
happened with Watergate and things are
going to get bigger before they get
smaller and that brings us to
impeachment if these allegations are
true can the president be impeached
you'll be able to find a detailed
breakdown of what constitutes an
impeachable offense in a video that I'm
working on release in a couple of days
but experts have already started to
weigh in on whether repeatedly asking a
foreign country to investigate a
political opponent is impeachable
whether there is an express quid pro quo
or not if the president asked the
president of Ukraine to investigate the
Biden's in exchange for already promised
aid the Trump has leveraged a foreign
government into helping him to defeat a
political opponent this would be a gross
abuse of presidential power and most
people point to the triggering of
impeachment being high crimes and
misdemeanors but people forget that
impeachment is triggered not only by
high crimes and misdemeanors but also
treason and bribery and I think bribery
is the operative word there the u.s.
code 18 USC 201 deals with a bribery of
public officials and witnesses scholars
disagree on whether that particular
statute applies to the press
but clearly that statute would be
subsumed into the general statement that
bribery is enough to trigger impeachment
of the President of the United States
and the facts as we know them could lend
themselves to a conclusion that the
president's solicited bribery from a
foreign official in the form of
political dirt on a political rival in
exchange for releasing foreign aid to
Ukraine and as former federal prosecutor
Renato Mariotti points out whether this
actually fits into the specific bribery
statute or federal election statutes
misses the point this is more than just
a garden-variety crime it's worse as he
points out mere bribery probably
understates the magnitude of the
malfeasance here what is alleged is a
draw chopping abuse of power the
criminal process is equipped to deal
with us and even if it were it's
possible the DOJ can't indict a sitting
president and let's say it doesn't meet
the technical definition of bribery
because the statute doesn't apply to the
president as the head of state or
sovereign immunity applies critics will
then say everything is all good because
it's not bribery itself whether these
actions meet the strict definition of
bribery we know now that the president
has used the power of his office to dig
up dirt from foreign officials the
transcript confirms if not an explicit
quid pro quo at the very least a very
strong implied quid pro quo this could
be solicitation of a bribe but it's
definitely an abuse of power pure and
simple okay I thought I was done I
thought today would be a good day to get
a haircut but no apparently I need this
somehow link the scandal to Skillshare
which is one of my favorite sponsors but
you know still you know I guess getting
smaller countries to do what you want
takes persuasion and if you need to
pressure foreign powers into
investigating political rivals there's
no skill that you need to hone more than
your persuasion skills and with skill
shares storytelling for leaders course
you'll learn how to bribe and blackmail
without getting impeached as a leader
it's up to you to communicate
meaningfully about your work
and your aspirations as whether it's for
marketing materials a client
presentation unifying story to fire up
your team or to convince a foreign
president to investigate your political
rivals Keith Yamashita will teach you
how to craft a compelling story that
matters to your audience even if your
audience is the president of Ukraine oh
it's fun to joke when Rome is burning
isn't it but seriously this is actually
a really good course all kidding aside
Skillshare is an online learning
community that has tens of thousands of
classes on everything like music design
technology and business legal eagles
we'll get to three months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below plus it
really helps out the channel the free
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to must know topics so you can
improve your skills and learn new things
all free for two months so get skills
share and improve yourself now so you
can start getting your dirt on your
political ponents immediately do you
agree with my grade are you as worried
about the republic as I am leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real law reviews over here
where I will see you in court I guess